نحن في احد اقسام مستشفى ناصر في جنوب
قطاع غزه تحديدا في محافظه خان يونس نتحدث
الان مع احد الاطفال الذين لهم حكايه مع
حكايات الوجع والالم والفقد حكايه سيف ابو
حطب والذي فقد عددا كبيرا من افراد
عائلته
وابوي واخويا انا سيف الدين عادل عادل
صبحي ابو حطب عمري 10 سنين بصف خامس
بمدرسه سمو الشيخ حمد انا سالت عمي وين
امي وابوي قاللي بمصر بتعالج قلت له ماشي
بعدين بعد اسبوع اسبوعين انا حالي حسيت
قلبي حاسس انه امي وابوي استشهدوا سالنا
عن اخوه عماد قلت له يا عمي
استشهد وبعدين ما حكيتله خلص صرت اقول له
لقيت تسالش عن حاجه في حالك لقيت صحتك اهم
شيء امهم سالني عن امه وابوه حكيت له امك
وابوك تعالجوا ايش اضطرينا نكذب على ووللد
نقول له ام وابوه انه بتعالج في مصر
العنايه وصار كل يوم الولد يسالنا عن امي
وابوي طب ليش انت ما بتتصل فيهم مثلا
تكلمهم احكي لله يا عمي ما فيش اتصالات ما
انت شايف صرت امهد له شوي شويه انه عمك
محمد
استشهد عمك ابو وائل اللي مستشهد الله
يرحمه خالتك رانيا ستك اخر شيء صرت اضن
احكي للولد اكش يسال يا عمي صحتك صرت اقول
له انه انتبه لحالك هلقيت لانه ما فيش انت
شايف الوضع الا هو لحاله يوم من الايام
بكي لي عمي
طيب انا حاسس انه امي وابوي استشهدوا
مستشهدين قلت له والله يا عمي بدك الصراحه
هذا بعد ما طلع يعني ب 25 يوم العينيه
وصار يقعد قلت له بدك الصراحه الحمد لله
الش كنت عادي يوم من الايام قصفه
الدار انا صحيت لقيت حال بالمستشفى وهذا
استشهدوا عمامي وامي وابوي واخوي وخالاتي
خمسه وستي
النتين معك اخواتي النتين اللي عاشوا وبنت
عمي بس عدد الشهداء
32 متى حتطلع ان شاء الله من المستشفى بس
ان شاء الله يطيب الجرح
واتحسن كل يوم بغير لي بس غيروا لي بتحسن
الجرح بطيب بطلع
بسطيف داخل المشافي غزه تترافق قصص اوجاع
الفقد مع الام الاصابه هنا يحاول الاطباء
شفاء اصابات الجسد لكن اوجاع الفقد ليس
لها
برؤ لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان
يونس جنوب قطاع غزه